Hey guys, and welcome to another
moneymaking guide. Uh, today I'm going
to be showing you a method that can make
you up to 1.1 mil an hour as with
current prices. Uh, but I'm also going
to break down a couple other different
ways you can do it uh that will give you
different levels of profit, but
different levels of uh safety and high
risk and low risk. Definitely different
options for different types of people,
high requirements and low requirements.
So, stick around and uh let's get
started. All right, guys. So, today we
are going to try to buy some death runes
uh from a couple different places. Uh to
start with, we're going to try the uh
Mage of Zamre in the wilderness. Uh so,
we're going to bring some food for that.
Afterwards, we're going to try Alibaba's
magic shop. And I think we're going to
try a uh the magic guild as well um to
see where we can buy death runes and see
how much money we can make uh in an hour
theoretically doing that. Uh because
like um a lot of people have been
mentioning right now, the price of death
runes is extremely high. Uh you can see
here it's 363 as of the most current
prices. It was up to almost 400 uh last
week. Uh so yeah, it's going to be
really profitable to buy runes from
shops. So we're going to go ahead try
three different ones and see how they
work. All right, so for the first method
I'm going to try, I'm going to be buying
from the Mage of Zamrack. Uh to do this
effectively, you will need to have done
uh the abyss mini quest, but that is
like a really super easy quest. Get up
here, freaky forester. Uh yeah, it
doesn't have much requirements and it's
super easy to do. Just need, I think,
seven room craft. No, you can do it
level one room crafting anyway. Uh so
what we're going to do is run here into
the wilderness. Now, I'd recommend at
least some basic mele gear and some food
because it's not likely, but
occasionally you will get attacked. I
would also recommend bringing any weapon
just because you will need to fight some
skeletons because they will be
aggressive uh for quite a while
unfortunately. God, [__] off. Um so it's
kind of nice if you can kill them quick.
And then you're just going to buy death
runes from the mage of Zamarak. It's
pretty damn easy. I'm kind of getting
the feeling like this might be the best
place to do this right now. Uh cuz it is
more risky of course. So probably less
people buying runes from here right now.
So we'll go ahead and do this just for
10 minutes or so. Uh, it looks like
since the price of death runs is so
high, you can almost buy out the entire
shop.
Uh, 360. Yeah, we'll probably stop
there. But yeah, all you do then is hop
worlds and repeat. Pretty easy to do.
And yeah, so we'll come back in 10
minutes and see how many uh death runes
we managed to buy. All right, so that
took quite a bit less time than I
thought it was going to only about 4
minutes. Uh, the death rune shops, I
found a couple good worlds that had 300
in them. Um, but most of them had 200,
but still still very profitable even to
buy them down to like what I'm at now,
80, even as low as 50. You can see my
timer here. I'm just down to like six
minutes pretty well. Uh, so really only
4 minutes to spend 500k. Now, there's
two strategies you could do here. You
could opt into bringing high level gear
um and bringing lots of money. The
benefit here is because um the monsters
will stoping you after a while, you'll
probably make more per hour if you bring
more money. That being said, I would
prefer myself to just bring 500k, bank
every 5 minutes or 10 minutes, and then
you're not risking nearly as much. Uh,
because you'd have to bring three, four
mil or something like that to be able to
do this for an hour straight. So, I'd
recommend just banking frequently, and
really helps mitigate the risk. All
right, so we're just going to check the
price of death runes. Looks like it's at
364 right now. Uh, so they're going to
instantly sell pretty well for 364. Uh
but it looks like we're going to get
about
576k
roughly. Uh so it'll be a 75k profit or
77k or something uh which isn't bad. And
uh per hour that's looking like about
uh 1.1 mil. So pretty nice. And we'll go
ahead and check out the next shop. Oh,
it's called the Wizards Guild. Uh
incoming flaming for sure. Uh but
anyway, so to get into the Wizards
Guild, you will need 66 magic. Uh that
is a much higher requirement and
honestly the reward isn't going to be
that great because I believe a lot of
people are going to be buying from this
shop. That being said, it is much safer.
I can see now it's the wrong one. Um Rob
store owner. Nope. Where's the correct
wizard we need here? This one. There we
go. Uh so you can see the death runes
are totally bought down. Uh, that being
said, the 10 we could get here are
pretty cheap for 225. So, I think it's
actually cheaper than the um uh the
wilderness shop or sorry, the Zamrack
made shop. Um, oh my god, why are there
people there? Uh, one thing you really
do not want to do is hop into a PvP
world. When I was testing this out
before I made the video, I accidentally
did that. Luckily, I survived. But um
yeah, I wouldn't really recommend doing
it cuz there was actually somebody
camping there. Uh which is a little bit
unfortunate. Um so we'll go ahead and do
this for we'll set a timer for 10
minutes and uh I'm expecting to make
quite a bit less, but we'll see how much
we can make and we'll be back in a
minute. Okay, so we got drastically less
uh death runes. That is from 10 minutes,
not even from five. Uh that means that
we did get probably a better margin on
all the items. Uh it'll be interesting
to see how much we made in would have
made in an hour of doing this. We found
a couple worlds that were reasonably
full, but for the most part, there were
a ton of people doing this. Uh because
it's safe, there's no risk. And while I
do need 66 magic, it's not really that
high a requirement. All right, once
again, we're selling them for 363. So
291.
Uh they're pretty much instantly sold.
There we go. Uh so we got
Oh, surprisingly more.
Interesting. Uh well I'm surprised in
some ways while it was 10 minutes so we
are going to make less per hour. It's
actually quite a bit more uh per
minor coin spent. So we got well I guess
113k
in um 10 minutes. So per hour we be
looking at about 700k uh which is still
really solid for what it is considering
how packed the worlds were. Um it's
actually really good if you manage to
get on a time where there weren't many
people doing it. You can get easily up
to 1 mil an hour doing this as well. Uh
but 700k for a safe money maker I think
is pretty good. And yes, so we'll move
on to Alibaba's shop and see how it
compares to the rest. All right, and for
the last shop of the video, we are going
to be doing uh Alibaba's rune shop. Now,
this one you do need Lunar Diplomacy to
have access to, so it's definitely a
much higher requirement, but this is
looking pretty promising so far. Um so
death runes again are 360.
Oh, they go up in price quite a bit
more. Uh, so we can probably buy them
down to 160
and still be profitable.
Yeah, but 160 I wouldn't go past that
though. Uh, but still the world was
reasonably full, so that's a good sign.
Um, of course you would benefit from
buying more stuff from the rune shop
theoretically, but we're just testing
death runes right now. And uh, yeah, I
mean even these worlds you can buy down
a bit more. Um, so yeah, we'll go ahead
and try this out for 10 minutes again,
and we'll see the result. Okay, so in 10
minutes, I was able to buy 1,775
death runes. I'm not really sure where
this is going to fall in with the other
uh two methods. I kind of get a feeling
it might be the worst, surprisingly. Uh,
but let's go ahead and check. So, death
rune. Uh, once again, let's just double
check the price.
It's going to be 363.
and we're going to sell it for 644.
Um, so 644
plus 504 minus 1 mil and it sold so
quick already. So 1148k.
Um,
so 149k we made in 10 minutes times 6 is
going to be actually 900k an hour. I
take that back. So this again is pro
realistically this is probably the best
method. uh secure and um no PKs. On top
of that, I was only buying death runes.
You can buy other items as well. Um but
for the most money, you're going to want
to do the Zamrack mage and he has a much
lower requirement. So, they're kind of a
benefit to all of these. Um if you want
security at a reasonably low
requirement, go with the M or Wizard
Guild. If you want a low requirement and
high risk but high reward, Samur Mage
and um just kind of more of a solid high
requirement method is going to be Alib
Baba's Made Shop. So, I hope you guys
enjoyed the video and uh find it useful.
Price of death rune is definitely making
this viable right now. So, give it a try
and uh yeah, hope you enjoyed and we'll
see you guys in the next video.
[Music]